et parmi les prisonniers de guantanamo
mansoura d'achille a passé à 14 ans dans
cette prison sans pour autant être
inculpé il a accepté de témoigner pour
alerter regardez
plein
d'astuces
est un lieu qui sème la haine et
l'injustice guantanamo est aujourd'hui
un symbole de la torture de l'injustice
de l'illégalité de l'abus de pouvoir
guantanamo est l'un des violateurs
principaux des droits de l'homme au
21ème siècle je suis étonné par le
silence de la part de la communauté
internationale par ces pays vous savez
il ne s'agit pas de guantanamo des
musulmans ou de la prison là il s'agit
de nous tous du coup si on parle de
guantanamo c'est un trou noir qui a été
créé à l'extérieur du système judiciaire
aucune loi ni marche aucun des droits de
l'homme aucune norme leed roi de base en
matière des droits de l'homme guantanamo
son existence c'est de la torture c'est
de l'injustice exister cette tâche
moi je suis aussi une victime de
l'utilisation abusive de la loi à la
suite des événements du 11 septembre je
ne vais pas dire que j'en suis heureux
ils nous poussent à le dire nous
essayons de communiquer avec eux en
disant que nous avez vous fait ce n'est
pas bon du tout il avait voulu extraire
les pires de nous-mêmes je me souviens
toujours de ces jours là jusqu'à ce jour
la même question pourquoi j'étais là
pourquoi on m'a torturé pourquoi on a
abusé de moi pourquoi j'ai perdu près de
15 ans de ma vie je ne pense pas que les
familles même des victimes des
événements du 11 septembre lors été mais
je ne pense pas qu'elle en soit contente
non plus bas bien partout